in this video we'll talk about monkey
box virus
cases of monkey pox virus is spreading
all across the world
it has been reported from several
countries including united states united
kingdom canada and many more most of the
cases are from united kingdom and
portugal
why it is known as monkey pox monkey pox
virus was first identified in 1958 from
lab monkeys in denmark
from then it was called as monkey pox
the first case of human was discovered
in congo in 1970
and from then there are many other cases
which are reported worldwide
this particular virus is a enveloped
double-stranded dna virus it belongs to
the family of pox vdd that means it's a
close cousin of chickenpox and smallpox
virus
now let's see how this virus can be
transmitted it can be transmitted from
animals like monkeys squeal dormouse or
gambian pouch rat to human via scratches
bites or consuming bush meat of these
particular animals the natural reservoir
for monkey pox has not yet been
identified but it is thought that the
rodents could be the most likely
reservoir for this particular virus
this virus can spread when you touch a
body fluid of infected animal or you get
scratched by an infected animal this
virus can enter your screen
through this kind of cuts or breaches
human to human transmission occurs when
you have droplet so respiratory droplet
is the key source of infection other
than that touching body fluids or
contaminated objects can also lead to
transmission of these viruses this
particular virus can cross placenta that
means it can be transmitted from mother
to the
newborn scientists are still thinking
that whether this virus can be
transmitted sexually
among the infected individual worldwide
several people are from the lgbtq
community that is why cdc is warning and
thinking that probably they are more
susceptible to these kind of infection
though this is not clear and more
research is required to understand
whether it's a sexually transmitted
disease or not
anyway let's talk about the symptoms of
monkey pox the invasion period lasts
between 0 to 5 days
so first there would be fever
severe headache and the characteristic
feature is lymph adenopathy that means
swelling of your lymph nodes
and this is pretty characteristic of
this particular disease it is not found
in chicken pox or small box infection
now other than that there could be lack
of energy back pain muscle pain which
are pretty common rashes appear after
one to three days of fever
and most of the rashes are found in this
faces and other extremities like
soul of your palm of soul of your foot
and palm of your hand
in many cases rashes are also visible in
oral mucosa and in rare cases in
genitalia
question is how long does this disease
last
in most common cases the disease would
last for two to four weeks but in severe
cases it might last for several months
if you are an immunocompromised
individual the work the outcome might be
worse
now monkey pox virus can be diagnosed
using
looking at the clinical symptoms such as
rashes but these are not definitive
features of this particular disease it
can be common between other type of pox
as well but lymphadenopathy is pretty
characteristics of monkey pox virus and
discriminate it from other type of boxes
but the ultimate
diagnosis can be done using rt pcr just
like the covid test so any kind of virus
can be detected using rtpcr based
diagnostic tools
now there are no current vaccine which
is dedicated against this particular
virus but the existing smallpox smallpox
vaccine is pretty efficient to eradicate
this kind of um
infection
so
in 2019 cdc has given permission for a
new vaccine which is basically a
modified attenuated ankara strain of
vasina virus so this can be used to
prevent the spread of monkey pox
monkey box treatment options involve
taking antibiotics to reduce the fever
reducing the pain
also you can consume enough amount of
body fluids such that you are not
dehydrated
taking adequate rest is mandatory but in
case of extreme infection cdc prescribes
several antiviral medications and
immunoglobulins for the treatment
anyway prevention is better than cure
monkey box virus prevention can be done
by reducing the risk of contact and it
is possible because this is more visual
and the individual affected can be
isolated very easily
and it is unlike kovid right so animal
to human transmission can be reduced by
reducing the contact between animals and
humans so reducing that zoonotic
transmission is really important
especially in
developing countries
and preventing uh
preventing all the animal trades and
animal markets could be a good option to
prevent the spread
so i hope this particular video was
useful if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe you can support my
channel uh by using uh
the super like option in youtube which
appears just below the video
you can get more flash card notes
regarding many biology topics in my
facebook page link is provided in the
description you can get dynamic flash
card which would help your vision
as usual don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can take my courses in